ich versuche mich von nichts zu einem
Porsche hoch zu arbeiten es gibt 700.000
Golfer in Deutschland und von denen
werden im Jahr ungefähr 7,5 Millionen
Bälle verhauen und einige davon landen
eben auch in den Seen die es auf den
Golfplätzen gibt diese sogenannten
lakeboys sind obwohl sie gebraucht sind
und im Wasserlagen bis zu 2 € Wert also
rein ins taucherhoutfit
gijo auf dem Weg sich kostenloses Geld
abzuheben und noch nicht mal zwei
Minuten wurde mir klar wir stehen in
einer verdammten Gold ich habe wirklich
säckeweise Bälle aus dem See geholt und
es wurde nicht weniger egal wo ich
hingegriffen habe es waren immer noch
Bälle zu holen also viel zu viel um den
See komplett alleine leer zu machen
zurück im Büro haben wir die guten von
schlechten Wellen getrennt dabei geht's
um Alter Zustand Marke und noch ein paar
andere Punkte schätzungsweise haben wir
so ca 80 € in dieser eine Stunde
rausgeholt das reicht uns aber natürlich
nicht wir müssen noch mal hin und mehr
rausholen und vor allem mehr von den
teuren Bällen raus ich hoffe ihr seid
genauso geil wie ich wie viele Bälle da
noch im Leben weil